we're doing pass or smash fake it till
you make it mentality pass there's a lot
of value in it but I think it's
misunderstood when you're faking it till
you make it there's a level of
manipulation going on let me wear the
suit I mean there's a lot of lying that
comes along with it so I think fake it
to you make it would be a little bit
different have conviction that you're
gonna make it and act as if that's very
different than fake it to you make it
which comes with a lot of baggage of
like sleazy behavior that actually can
become very dangerous because you cut
become used to it and then when you make
it some of those things that got you
there with the faking it actually become
your scarlet letter and your
vulnerability of losing it so fake it to
you make it may lead to you losing it
but have conviction that you're going to
make it and acts to act as if becomes a
healthier version of it